بدا الجيش الايراني والحرس الثوري
ومناورات مشتركه للدفاعات الجويه هدفها
تعزيز حمايه الاجواء الايرانيه والدفاع عن
المراكز الحيويه في البلاد وخلال اليوم
الاول من المناورات تم اختباره منظومات
عده محليه الصنع اصابت اهدافا افتراضيه
تمثلت في صواريخ كروز وطائرات مسيره
وشملت المناورات اجراء تمرينات على الحرب
الالكترونيه كما تم الكشف لاول مره عن
انفاق تضم منظومات دفاع جويه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رست سفينتان حربيتان ايرانيتان في ميناء
مدينه ريو دي جانيرو في البرازيل بعد
موافقه الحكومه البرازيليه وقالت اداره
الميناء ان سفينتين الحربيتين ايريس
ماكرون
وسلطه صباح الاحد وقالت رويترز ان الرئيس
البرازيلي وافق على رسوم سفينتين بعد ان
عرض ذلك قبيل سفره للقاء الرئيس الامريكي
في واشنطن نهايه شهر يناير الماضي